hi guys so a couple of weeks ago I asked
you the questions that you'd like to be
answered by an officially top college
type person and I have one here this is
Maddie who's our JCL access rep John
briefly explained that means yes so I'm
the access rep I get elected I got
elected into my position basically to
represent the JCR
on issues of access and admissions so my
job is to ensure like an equal and fair
admissions process for incoming students
so we have your questions here we're
just going to sort of go through them
one by one I guess so the first question
is you can't get in unless you've got
masses of extracurriculars and
impressive things other than grades well
I think a lot of people here do you do
extracurricular stuff but I don't think
even I don't think it's true they're
mitad because of it I mean really the
only thing that you just care about is
your grades and how good you are at your
subject I think other things like sports
or music demonstrate you can time manage
yeah idea fishel answer I have from the
admissions team is that they're only
interested in academics so if you've got
extracurriculars are related to
academics like if you work in a museum
or if you've done some lab work or
something like web as related to your
subject that'll be helpful they're not
really interested if you can do all
really well or play musical instrument
or do support this is business for
Oxford specifically like other movies
may be interested to hear that but I
offered it's purely about the academics
unlike Simon said it might demonstrate
you can time manage but they're not
going to not let you work just because
you can't play like a classical dollars
I think there's definitely some to be
said there about doing stuff that's
related to a subject yeah that's how
because I think one of the big things
are looking for is like passion about
your subject no interested you are so
yeah so if you're doing hist if you're
applying to do history you volunteer at
Museum and that's obvious being a really
good next question
someone who's been on free school meals
for most of their life but came off the
mid-year 11 are they entitled to any of
bursaries or whatever the songs still on
females will get and will that help or
hinder chances of success yeah so Oxford
does
possible opportunities bursaries and and
that's it's kind of like it's
means-tested and it's on a sliding scale
and it's really generous so I think even
household incomes up to like forty
thousand pounds you can still get some
level of the bursaries and the lower
your household income the higher your
bursaries will be and that's on top of
any bursaries or grants or loans that
you'll get from the government as well
so that that's the optimal opportunities
but is there another not if specifically
relates to fiscal meals I don't think
yeah I mean the free school meals I
don't know if it will be taken into
account if you're not on them before you
come into university but you'll have to
check the website but the main thing
will be your household income so if you
were eligible for free school meals then
your heart'll link and will probably
reflect that and you'll be entitled to
certain bursaries and certain colleges
as well offer a lot of financial support
on top of the government support and the
autumn bursaries I heard these from
frightened applicants applying to Oxford
back in high school apparently there was
this myth probably running running
around about one of the interviewers
pointing out that the applicant being
interviewed had written in the personal
statement that they were really good at
the piano there was a piano in the room
so the interviewers ask the applicant to
play the piano never heard that one no
and that's your reason excuse me um yeah
they probably asked you to do that ya
know like I said about the
extracurriculars they don't apply to
your application so you're not going to
be asked to play the piano unless you're
going for like a piano scholarship or
something like that
they're not going to ask you to do
anything you know they're going to ask
you questions about your subject they
were asking to do anything that's like
radically outside that area I think I
think the problem with interviews is
that there's so many myths which fly
around because so few people go up to
Oxford Avenger interview yeah that you
hear these stories and people tend to
believe them yeah I mean the very the
best on which I've heard which is true
was that a guy at a college near us
you're not going to name it was applied
for engineering had an interview was so
nervous willing to be finished
that instead of getting up and leaving
by the door he got up and walked into a
wardrobe yes and then stayed in there
for the next interview he was too
frightened to leave so unless you're
that guy I don't think you know that's
nothing like that's probably going to
happen to you but they're not going to
make you do something like that
and like all those things about like if
you catch a football you're in yeah like
there's so many events do not believe
them interviewers are actually human
beings they're not going to make you do
weird crazy stuff yeah unless it's
related to your session when they want
you to do well that's the thing they
actively want you to do well yeah
so yes answer from that is no you're not
going to be asked to do anything really
strange it's it's going to be relatively
straightforward next question how much
free time are usually entitled to with
all the work in Oxford
I don't would you say I think it varies
I think very few Tyrian subject subject
yeah I'd say it's definitely subject
dependent obviously Sciences are sort of
more structured you'll have a lot more
contact time whereas with arts you'll be
expected to do more of your own reading
you might really have like
I don't give a figure and muscle wrong
but like you might only have a certain
number of hours a week but then you'll
be expected to do like double that
amount of your own reading research I
think it's normally something like four
to five like four two tens and that it's
like me number of contact hours I think
for humans I think the science is is
well I had probably the region of twenty
to thirty yeah I think I have in first
year at twenty one contact hours so
there's this plenty of time I mean to me
ninety physics which is kind of known as
being one more time demanding subjects
yeah and I most evenings you could have
three or you could work in the evenings
have the weekend off or whatever you
know you can eat well this is the
classic examples as a guide there below
me who is a physicist who's in the
University of Auckland he might be
rowing in a boat race and that takes up
an awful lot of time every day so you
know especially if you're good at time
management in school as you know you can
definitely do things you find
interesting outside your subject yeah
definitely and there's so much to do and
also the number of contact hours is not
really important even if you do have
like twenty one contact hours a week
that's still less than you have at
school and at school you still manage to
do like all your lessons and your
homework I'm still do fun stuff quickly
so don't worry about having don't about
not having enough free time because you
will but time manage with it to keep it
yeah I think it takes some getting used
to and in first year I found actually
that it was like you were in school your
time is structured for you and when you
get here it is destructive but you have
so much more freedom that you like I
ended up just working all the time
because that's yeah yeah that's what you
do in school yeah that might be you and
yet it's once you get here you figure
out if you're doing a-levels you
probably pretty good at managing your
time anyway and once you get here you'll
suddenly learn how to do it but yeah I'd
like everyone here still manages to go
out do activities and sports and stuff
and still do what they want to do it's
not like you're going to be stuck at
your desk all day whole like it just
eats your stereotype this is boring yeah
it's not really fun I'm like busy people
have more fun I think this I don't you
know I just want to be okay sitting
around all day doing nothing